[Música]
hoy vengo a contarles una historia de
iluminación y no solo de iluminación
sino de clarificación de ideas y de
identificación de oportunidades
recientemente tuve la oportunidad de
trabajar en uno de los centros de
investigación más reconocidos en
latinoamérica y creo que lo primero que
me pude dar cuenta y lo más importante
es que en el mundo abundan tres cosas
en este mundo abundan tres cosas la
primera de ellas son personas
somos siete mil millones de personas
según
la onu y para el 2050 2035 perdón
seremos 9000 millones de personas esto
quiere decir 9 mil millones de personas
que alimentar que educar y que incluir
en nuestras sociedades la segunda cosa
que abunda en este mundo son datos según
estudios en eeuu se generan por segundo
más de 7000 tweets más de 50 mil
búsquedas en google y se generan se
envían más de 2 millones de mails esto
quiere decir una infinidad de datos con
la cual tenemos que lidiar día a día y
la tercera cosa que completan esta
ecuación de caos y de abundancia son
problemas y creo que esto no tenemos que
dar estadísticas todas las conocemos
problemas de desnutrición analfabetismo
violencia inseguridad inclusión social
con las que lidiamos todos nosotros
porque están aquí latente mente en
latinoamérica
entonces pensando en etapa investigador
debe haber algunas herramientas
exacto las hay el ser humano es un ser
social por naturaleza y se ha dado a la
tarea a identificar estos problemas ya
identificar soluciones o tratarlos de
solucionar el problema es que con tantos
datos tantas personas y tantos problemas
la hoja de ruta se ve algo como esto
donde no sabemos por dónde comenzar no
sabemos cuál es el camino y no sabemos
dónde termina nuestro esquema
entonces debemos encontrar herramientas
en la que converjan estos tres factores
los problemas las personas y los datos
y si hay es la segunda buena noticia
existen organizaciones y ting tings que
se han dado a la tarea de uno de
nuestros datos organizarlos y
trasladarlos hacia todas las personas de
forma legible con cualquier persona
puede utilizar y entender estos datos
índices como el índice de competitividad
el índice de libertad económica incluso
el doing bussiness que lo realiza el
banco mundial pueden darnos muchísimas y
muchísima información y son de gran
riqueza para obtener oportunidades para
identificar oportunidades en las cuales
actuar lamentablemente y por la
naturaleza competitiva del ser humano la
única discusión que se genera es similar
a la del ranking de la fifa en donde la
principal discusión es quién está
primero quién está el último cómo se
movieron las posiciones cómo cayó tu
país dónde está costa rica dónde está
guatemala cómo que si la vida fuera un
partido de fútbol y no nos damos cuenta
que estamos desperdiciando la gran
riqueza
en estos en estas herramientas
y es que no desperdiciemos estas
herramientas que agarremos estas
herramientas y encontremos los problemas
e identifiquemos las soluciones que
pueden solucionar estos problemas
busquemos el financiamiento para estas
soluciones busquemos la manera de
ponerlas en práctica y con de nuevo con
estos índices medir el avance que
estamos teniendo en las implementaciones
y esto no es nada nuevo para nada nada
nuevo la aplicó que la más famosa y la
historia de éxito de la utilización de
un índice para generar algo está en
nueva york
los presento con stats este es el
sistema con el cual la policía de nueva
york luego la reducción del 75% de la
criminalidad de la ciudad de manhattan
de nuevo a través de un índice
identificaron a manhattan como una de
las ciudades de mayor criminalidad en
todo eeuu
a través de la colaboración de la
iniciativa privada y el gobierno se
logra la implementación de un sistema
colaborativo en el que los ciudadanos de
manhattan pueden publicar incidentes de
criminalidad y a la policía de nueva
york le permite focalizar recursos y
reducción de costos de nuevo esto se
origina a través de un índice la segunda
historia de éxito pasa acá en
latinoamérica
se llama connect citizens de río de
janeiro esta iniciativa surgió porque en
el 2013 se venía para la ciudad de río
de janeiro la jornada mundial de la
juventud católica y se buscaba se
preveía de que iba a ser un caos vial y
un caos social entonces la municipalidad
de nuevo analizando sus índices donde la
ciudad de arriba aparecía con uno de los
índices de infraestructura más bajos de
brasil lograron identificar este caos
que se venía y con una alianza con ways
y su programa de connected cities tings
lograron implementar un sistema que
permite el monitoreo el tráfico el
monitoreo de las personas y también
permite la focalización de recursos
dicho sea de paso está esta iniciativa
tardó sólo tan solo dos semanas en
implementarse y hoy por hoy es la es la
solución con la ha sido con la que la
ciudad del río de janeiro ni en su
tráfico y reduce costos y focalizar
recursos
y la tercera solución o historia de
éxito se llama costa rica proponía se
está trabajando actualmente acá costa
rica propone y lo que hizo costa rica
fue tomar uno de los índices y medir los
a nivel cantonal buscando la manera
identificar los problemas que afectan en
cada uno de los cantones de la ciudad el
de costa rica
nueva identificación de problemas hoy
por hoy están trabajando en talleres
para darle solución a cada uno de estos
problemas ya identificados a nivel
cantonal que estos son los verdaderos
problemas que nos afectan a cada uno de
nosotros como ciudadanos de estas de
estos cantones
entonces como ven los índices tienen una
gran riqueza y lo que yo vengo a
proponer aquí es que no desperdiciemos
de información de estos índices que
tomemos los índices y generemos una
cultura de innovación negocios políticas
públicas y programas de responsabilidad
social basadas en datos o como nosotros
le llamamos basadas en índices así que
los invito a que revisemos de nuevo
estos índices e identifiquemos
oportunidades para construir
verdaderamente la latinoamérica que
todos queremos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]